bonsoir a régalé dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sociétés ce soir on va
s'intéresser à l'avenir de l'université
de versailles saint quentin le 19 mars
dernier le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche débloquer
une enveloppe de 2,6 1 millions d'euros
sous forme d'avancé remboursable pour
permettre donc à lui vécu de présenter
un budget 2014 conforme une avances
conditionnées à des efforts à consentir
un peu plus d'un mois plus tard
alors nous avons voulu savoir si des
choses avaient changé si les efforts
avaient été effectivement consentis et
qu'elle pouvait être notamment les
inquiétudes des différents corps
représentés au sein de cette université
alors autour de cette table brigitte sur
un bon soir vous êtes responsable se
résume à versailles vous est également
professeur de mathématiques en face
d'eux ou céline dumoulin bonsoir vous
aurez présenter le personnel et vous
êtes secrétaire général cgt au sein de
l'ue vs q et puis enfin laura and after
bonsoir vous êtes la présidente d'inter
asos ubs qu une fédération qui regroupe
quatorze associations étudiantes et
puisque reçues précise que nous avions
convient à un représentant de la
présidence mais l'emploi du temps de ses
représentants n'étaient pas compatibles
avec cette émission alors composé
d'abord à chacune une première question
quand vous avez appris que le ministère
débloqué 2,6 millions d'euros est-ce que
ça a été un soulagement
brigitte ce service vous êtes 10 à
l'université est sauvé pas tout à fait
ça pour moi mais il faut peut-être
replacer sa dans le cadre justement des
difficultés financières de l'université
qui depuis cet automne son sont apparus
donc très importante et donc il y avait
une toute première participation de la
ministre de 800000 euros à la fin de
l'année 2013 qui ont servi juste à
éviter la cessation de paiement
et puis en 2014 les premières prévisions
de budget faisait état d' d'un besoin
d'environ 10 millions d'euros
et puis au premier os et à eau pour un
conseil d'administration de budget
présenté faisait état d'un manque 2,5 et
quelques millions d'euros de
fonctionnement seulement et donc on voit
bien que
politique de la ministre c'était de
donner un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu pour essayer ce sport il ya
vraiment un bras de fer qui s'est engagé
et donc 2,6
on voit bien que ça ne suffisait pas
c'était juste pour essayer de sauver
mois par mois pour permettre à l'inversé
de construire fonctionné bon alors
déficit voilà ces niveaux là vous
partager ce point de vue oui
complètement effectivement les 2,6
millions qui sont annoncés comme une
avance ne suffiront pas à faire
fonctionner l'université toute l'année
civile
impossible comme le rappelait
effectivement brigitte chauvin on avait
effectivement en début d'année un budget
qui donnait un déficit de 5 millions au
terme de fonctionnement déjà associé à
un plan de restriction budgétaire tout à
fait important qui se traduit notamment
par le gel des postes donc là on demande
encore des économies supplémentaires
ça veut dire que là les activités
première de l'université qui sont
l'enseignement et la recherche donc
directement en danger est menacée par
cette enveloppe qui ne suffira pas de
toute façon le ministère sera obligé de
débloquer à la rentrée 2014 des nouveaux
des nouveaux moyens pour fonctionner oui
effectivement il ya un espèce de jeu
comme ça qui est d'essayer d'avoir faire
fonctionner l'austérité le plus loin
possible pour donner le moins d'argent
dans un budget de l'état qui est
effectivement très contre alors à la
hauteur alors c'est 2 millions si ça
suffisait pas mais c'est un bon début
mais c'est pas suffisant donc clairement
le budget qui a été voté lors du conseil
d'administration du mode février dedans
il y avait déjà beaucoup de coupes
il y avait beaucoup de restrictions au
niveau des emplois donc c'est à dire le
premier poste libéré est un premier
poste gelé donc du coup il n'ya plus
assez d'enseignants et par ailleurs on a
observé plusieurs autres coupes comme
par exemple concernant les bibliothèques
universitaires ou la santé des étudiants
où il ya des coupes par exemple pour la
santé on passe de 220 milles à 143 euros
et donc ce n'est même pas ce que ça ce
que ça veut dire concernant la santé des
étudiants parce que ça va impacter pour
eux pour revenir en biotech
universitaire le vrai changement
aujourd'hui
c'est par exemple vinothèque investor
qui seraient fermées donc le samedi
toute la journée avec qui habituellement
est ouvert de 8h à 18h et qui maintenant
va être fermé tous les samedis certains
disent quatre semaines dans le rapport
de la des biftons mon lit jusqu'au au
minimum novembre donc voilà il ya en
effet un bras de fer aussi entre les
l'administration qui me dit que 80 la
présence qui me dit que quatre semaines
et finalement dans les documents
officiels de l'administration qui nous
dit jusqu'à novembre donc c'est
complètement différent pour les études
vous avez l'impression que c'est une
situation du point du jour par jour mais
pas pratiquement du mois par mois y'a
pas de deux visions comme ça on essaie
aussi de nous faire de nous faire penser
ça mais je pense que la vision certains
l'ont quand même de façon assez claire
et depuis longtemps
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait que les
budgets qui été voté était un sincère
par exemple là on n'a pas découvert ça
quand même avoir un sincère pour
rappeler c'est à dire ce que le budget
est l'hôte à l'équipe puisque tu est
obligatoire et doit présenter un budget
avec nîmes que malgré tout ce n'était
pas un malgré tout un peu toujours faire
des prévisions de recettes qui sont trop
optimistes et dont on sait aller en
france qu'elles sont illicites
je veux justement qu'on est on évoque
pourquoi ces dérives je rapporte les
conclusions de la cour des comptes sur
la gestion de l'université entre 2006 et
université qui était placée sous la
présidence de civils fauchés et on va
voir sur le communiqué de presse
notamment du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche que les
propos sont quand même sévère puisque la
cour des comptes relève une augmentation
insuffisante insuffisamment maîtrisée
des emplois des recours excessif aux
heures complémentaires également deux
opérations de partenariat public-privé
dont celui de l'ufr de la santé qui a
généré des charges non prévues autour de
700 mille euros annuels et l'autre qui
portait sur des contrats de performance
énergétique qui ont conduit à doubler le
prix d'achat des les fluides
il ya eu également déçu révélation
surévaluation de dépenses et puis enfin
dernier point les mécanismes de contrôle
qui n'ont pas fonctionné alors quand on
découvre tout cela c'est très important
en 2d se dit
comment ça c'est personne n'est arrêté
ça je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
c'est à dire qu'il ya à la fois une
situation que vit l'univers lui est ce
qu actuellement mais que toutes les
universités j'ai malheureusement aussi
que c'est à dire qu'il ya effectivement
des choix quand même qu'ils sont faits
au niveau du ministère d'amendé par
exemple une enveloppe crédit impôt
recherche au détriment effectivement
d'un financement direct des universités
l'enveloppent le crédit impôt recherche
ccim il ya une enveloppe de 6 milliards
alors qu'on évalue à 350 millions
d'euros l'enveloppent nécessaires pour
remettre en état de fonctionnement
correct
l'ensemble des universités françaises
donc ça c'est la première chose il ya
quand même effectivement un choix du
ministère dans ce cadre là c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu une gestion on va dire assez
débridé est en tout cas une politique
ambitieuse alors que n'avait pas les
moyens de cette politique à l'université
de versailles saint quentin qui se
traduit notamment par effectivement la
signature des deux fameux partenariat
public privé l'un pour la construction
d'un bâtiment de l'ufr de médecine et
l'autre pour un contrat de performance
énergétique
donc oui mais voilà c'est sûr qu'il ya
eu enfin là on est à deux niveaux
effectivement deux de tes pensées de
situation dans laquelle nous mais le
ministère mais aussi d'une gestion
passée sur lequel effectivement le
rapport de la cour des comptes apporte
quand même déjà un certain nombre
d'éléments
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est quand même
pour la signature de ces ppp est là le
ministère quand même un discours assez
hypocrite ainsi que pour le vote des
budgets insincères que que signalait
bréchet de chauvin chaque fois les
procédures de contrôle elles ont un
garage quand même les représentants de
l'état où le ministère directement ça a
été le cas pour la signer alors que ces
opérations de contrôle sont qu elles
sont pas solides alors en fait elles
sont
elles sont dans le cadre d'une politique
générale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
donc voilà le recteur est au courant de
tout ce qui se battent au niveau des
budgets il est présent de lui en
personne ou une de ses assistantes et
paris présente directement lors des
conseils d'administration et il a tous
les budgets et il avoue enfin il avec
vote et voter pour vous feriez bien au
courant de tout ce qui se passait
aujourd'hui ça pourrait se reproduire ce
genre google ce qui est dans le cas du
regard de votre avis je vais me ans loos
pas tellement non parce que ce qu'on
appelle donc sous le sigle rce
responsabilités et compétences élargies
ce sont des jolis mots mais pour dire
quoi pour dire que les présidents
d'université sont autonomes et c'est
vrai que dans le cadre de la loi lru qui
date maintenant de dia ces sept embre
voilà 2007
bon ben il ya eu effectivement un
pouvoir extrêmement accrue accordée aux
présidents d'université et on en voit
les effets et les effets vont continuer
donc pour répondre à votre question oui
je crois que c'est encore possible
je reviens sont donc sur ces fameux deux
millions et demi d'euros qui ont été
complétés consentis par le ministère
sous forme d'avancé remboursable vous
avez lycée c'est pas assez
malgré tout ces deux millions ont été
versés je vois maintenant qu'on écoute
geneviève fioraso à des secrétaires
d'état d'aucun l'enseignement supérieur
et à la recherche
elle s'explique elle explique sur les
efforts qu'elle a demandé à l'université
est aussi elle demande un délai de deux
à trois ans nécessaires au redressement
que ce noyau on écoute nous avons aussi
demandé des efforts
quinze mille étudiants plus de 40 sites
d'implantation de cette université ça
n'était vraiment pas possible de camp
d'autant que certains de ces sites sont
remplies seulement pour le quart donc le
quart des bâtiments donc il y avait une
nationalisation opérait il y avait des
ppp 1 re négocier il y avait un sérieux
budgétaire à rétablir
et puis il y avait un accompagnement une
formation à la fois de l'équipe de
gouvernance et puis de l'équipe de
direction
c'est ce que nous avons fait puis je
crois que les universités doivent
trouver d'autres ressources
nous avons augmenté de 29% les moyens en
deux ans mais par exemple dans pour la
formation continue est une
vers cité ne vont pas suffisamment
chercher de ressources elles n'ont pas
suffisamment sur le proposer une offre
de formation pour la formation continue
et les entreprises n'ont pas non plus
l'habitude de s'adresser à elle donc là
il ya un effort à accompagner on va la
vendre à votre réaction sur les propos
de la secrétaire d'état donc il faut
mieux mutualiser les formations il faut
mieux rationaliser les bâtiments est-ce
que c'est là sur la rationalisation des
bâtiments on manque d'éléments là peut
être transmis par la direction de
l'université pour avoir quelque chose
d'assez concret mais il me semble pas
que quand vous entendez la ministre le
tenait justement il ya quarante
bâtiments pour 15 mhz et des fulgurances
et beaucoup de corps
certains sont ça paraît beaucoup de jeu
le mode l'entendant main dans ma mémoire
pour avoir été quand même assez assez
longtemps il y a dix sites 1
c'est à dire dix sites géographiques 1
dans les yvelines sur tout le
département dédié qui comme vous le
savez est très étendue donc
effectivement c'est beaucoup quarante
bon peut-être qu'on compte un bâtiment
dans un bâtiment plus bâtiment d'en face
de l'autre côté de la cour peut-être ça
ça fait 2 pour madame la ministre
bon voilà mais qui faillit rationaliser
bien sûr qu'il faut rationaliser je
pense que le travail est fait en ce sens
à tous les niveaux que ce soit dans
l'enseignement dans la recherche
maintenance des bâtiments oui ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il faut
balayer devant sa porte et qu'il faut
nationaliser ça je pense que la première
partie de son discours est raisonnable
pas après alors après sur wii moi je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à ce que
disait monsieur réseau dans les échos il
ya quelques temps où elle où elle a
écrit que les universités devait changer
de culture et devenir des centres de
profit
donc c'est ça que j'entends dans la
deuxième partie de son discours et alors
là
non enfin je pense pas que les
universités doivent être des centres de
profit
voilà je pense que si je vous pose la
question à toutes les deux vous allez
répondre paraît que vous complétez je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ensemble de la
communauté universitaire de l'ubs est ce
qu il ya eu des dérives qui ont été
faites par une petite partie de cette
communauté et que la majorité des
personnels et des étudiants du vs qu
sont des gens raisonnables soucieux des
deniers publics et qu' on n'est pas dans
l'ensemble une université qui
travaillent qui gaspille de l'argent
public moi ce que je vois au quotidien
c'est effectivement des collègues des
enseignants qui font des efforts pour
assurer malgré la situation très
difficile
l'ensemble de leurs missions de service
public d'enseignement pour assurer aux
étudiants des conditions d'études
les plus favorables que si c'est
justement par les situations difficiles
la ministre qui une fois sur un
redressement dans les deux trois ans ça
veut dire en gros encore des efforts à
faire alors qu'elle ait jamais eu un
plan a été mis en place
concrètement au quotidien comment ça se
traduit dans vos services à sétif est
globalement si pour les étudiants
comment ça se traduit ces efforts qui
sont demandés ça se traduit de multiples
façons je crois qu on trouve également
un pourri non moi je peux vous dire sur
l ufr de sciences s'est un peu tous
azimuts donc côté enseignement par
exemple et bien le budget a tellement
baissé pour l'ufr de sciences que on a
les enseignants ne peuvent plus faire de
photocopies ni de cours ni de travaux
dirigés pour les étudiants donc voila
quand même un problème c'est majeur les
labos des laboratoires de recherche qui
font pourtant qui sont extrêmement bien
évaluer qu'ils sont
tout à fait e
remarquable enfin voilà qui font du très
bon boulot on était des budgets ont été
amputés 2 75% donc il ya 25% de buts et
de fonctionnement pour les labos ça veut
dire que en deux puis partir en mission
on peut plus non plus en faire un peu
plus faire son travail de chercheur quoi
donc
et encore moi je suis en mathématiques
donc je connais moins les contraintes
des labos de sciences expérimentales
mais là je pense que doit être
absolument épouvantable quoi vous me
donnez d'avoir d'ailleurs l'exemple du
secteur de la biologie les enseignants
et chercheurs se sont rassemblés en
masse pour voir où est ce que vous
pouvez encore au absolument ben ils
disent non là on peut plus quoi le gel
de postes ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
assez de gens pour fonctionner les
budgets de fonctionnement en baisse il
vit déjà des suppressions de travaux
pratiques en première année de biologie
donc là stop arrêtez on ne peut plus
quoi on ne peut plus on peut plus du
côté des enseignants
du côté du personnel est-ce qu'on peut
plus non plus oui c'est la même
problématique est le même la même
effectivement baisse de 75% de
fonctionnement qui est aussi le lot des
services donc effectivement des services
notamment qui travaillaient sur des
projets à la n'est plus du tout les
capacités réaliser leurs activités bien
qu'on a vraiment de quoi survivre
pendant une année
mais sans mettre en place réellement
deux choses ah ça pour le personnel
s'ajoute la crainte effectivement
puisque côté personnel administratif et
technique qui a une grande partie de
personnel qui sont contractuels la
crainte est effectivement de voir leurs
contrats non renouvelés sachant qu'il ya
beaucoup de contrats qu'il arrive à
échéance en fin août 2014
donc cette enveloppe de 2 millions si ce
qui permet peut-être de fonctionné
jusque juillet août
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'elles vont
être les nouvelles mesures si
effectivement le ministère ne dégage pas
suffisamment d'argent pour reconduire le
personnel vous êtes au sein du
laboratoire printemps ces dames en
attendant de sociologie qui vous ça se
passe plutôt plutôt bien alors est ce
que c'est parce que vous avez du coût
des financements à la fois de
l'université à la fois du cnrs à la fois
des financements extérieurs c'est un
exemple à suivre
alors ça se passe pas bien ça
par exemple ça se traduit alors en
sciences humaines effectivement il ya
peut-être moins de deux oiseaux de nos
moyens en tout cas les moyens sont moins
importants pour fonctionner pour
réaliser des recherches quoique mais en
tout cas
nous ce dont on a cruellement besoin
s'est des postes des postes de soin
personnel administratif des ingénieurs
dans les labos et puis des postes de
chercheurs et d'enseignants chercheurs
pour réaliser les recherches donc ça les
postes c'est joli déjà ces vignerons a
plu la particularité des unités ce qu'on
appelle les unités mixtes de recherche
qui sont associés à la fois à
l'université et à des organismes de
recherche cnrs et qu'il ya quand même un
budget de l'autre tutelle qui est pas un
budget non plus incommensurable non ce
que ça ce que ça traduit c'est que ça
oblige effectivement à pour pouvoir
réaliser sa recherche d'aller chercher
des financements à l'extérieur mais avec
des financements qui sont contraints
aussi je dis enfin nous on est financé
principalement par les organismes
publics par les ministères les à nerfs
donc c'est voilà tout ça participe d'une
même enveloppe qui est contrainte à tous
les niveaux coin lors à la halle aux
toiles au niveau des tuyaux s'il ya des
inquiétudes a bien sûr il ya des
inquiétudes de tout voir parce que donc
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais pas
se libérer pour mieux poste gelé donc du
coup il ya monde enseignant la première
filière intacte et et ton la filière
staps actuellement qui au lieu de 80
cents oui le stade sans des sports et
donc qui au lieu d'avoir quatre
enseignants maintenant on a plus que
deux du coup pour la rentrée 2014 il va
y avoir une diminution de la capacité
d'accueil pour les étudiants donc ça
veut dire que les études des futurs
étudiants qui vont vouloir venir en aide
en staps ne vont pas par pouvoir
s'inscrire à lui est souvent ils vont
devoir aller ailleurs comme à nanterre
ou alors c'est donc comme l'a souligné
on a aussi une mission au niveau des
l'impression dépoli avant les étudiants
pour imprimer quelques feuilles donc
c'est une dizaine par jour est
maintenant assez 0 donc pareil les
enseignants ne peuvent pas imprimer les
feuilles de thé des du coup bas pour
travailler c'est forcément moins
efficace et moins pratique
par ailleurs il ya une augmentation du
nombre de cours magistraux et une
diminution des td alors que ce sont les
td qui font la qualité des enseignements
parce que du coup il ya un enseignant
pour un plus petit nombre d'étudiants ce
qui permet de plus facilement échanger
et de permettre de progresser assez
facilement parce que le
c'est un peu du coup bien se concentrer
sur les groupes d'étudiants qui l'a donc
ça sympa que sur la bibliothèque
universitaire donc on voit que l'abbé eu
231 yvelines va faire mais maintenant
tous les samedis mais il ya aussi celles
d'ambroise paris pour les externes qui
avant fermé à 22h30 maintenant ferme à
17h30
il ne pourra plus être ouverts non plus
le samedi alors que vous les externes
donc c'est un internat et qui ils
doivent passer le concours de l'internât
bon pour eux c'est forcément
problématique et depuis 2002 on n'a pas
acheté aucun livre aucun n'a été acheté
par l'université donc du coup bas des
potes civile tous les codes pour le
droit où n'importe quel livre qui est
d'habitude racheté en début d'année
n'est pas fait et du coup les étudiants
se retrouvent avec plein de bouquins un
jour ce qui est problématique pour eux
et doivent se renseigner ailleurs ou
acheter une violente et on voit cette
bibliothèque car universitaire quand
même quelques qualités derniers grands
bâtiments construits justement les
étudiants sont mobilisés pour les plus
vertueux que les comptines de le samedi
pour quel résultat
votre mobilisation bat pour le moment
pour pas grand chose j'attends toujours
qu'on accepte de me recevoir pour
pouvoir parler ça sont que parce que
j'aimerais justement savoir si ça va
être effectivement que quatre samedis ou
jusqu'à au mois de novembre parce qu'on
a quand même de deux forces qui
s'opposent et qui nous disent las des
choses complètement différentes 6 6 4
samedi
vraiment qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui
nous empêche de hull le faire au mois de
mai en pleine période de partiels et de
pas pouvoir les rejoindre plus tard août
hausse en septembre
ce ça paraîtrait plus logique en plus ça
nous permettra la mise nous de nous
retourner particulier moi je
j'accepterai devenir un samedi aider
gratuitement à l'université et je sais
qu'il ya des étudiants et des
associatifs qui veulent bien venir
un après midi une matinée où une journée
pour maintenir la bibliothèque
universitaire ouverte c'est aussi voilà
on sait tous la crise qu'est ce que cela
entraîne pour nous et on a tous envie de
se mobiliser mais pas au détriment de
tous les étudiants qui ont besoin de
t'apprendre et pareil pour le samedi il
ya aussi énormément de licence qui vient
de réviser leurs bagages
la bibliothèque est donc c'est aussi les
lycéens qui sont endommagés les
chercheurs place et c'est tout il ya
plus presque plus d'abonnements voilà
donc l'enseignement et la recherche sont
complètement intacte et avec toute cette
crise comment vous la sentez cette
rentrée de septembre 2014
j'ai l'impression de compliqué après un
peu arrosée en tout cas mais assurément
un peu grise est ce que vous avez fait
ce que je ressens déjà sur les
inscriptions sur les éléments de
renseignements des étudiants qui doivent
se dire ouh la la qu'est ce qu'on va
nous arriver si on vient étudier à
nouveau est ce que ça j'ai l'impression
que ce n'est pas tant que ça et
justement parce que ce que soulignait
ses lignes du moulin tout à l'heure
c'est à dire qu'il ya une telle prise de
conscience et puis une telle solidarité
en fait un des enseignants des
chercheurs est d'aider l'ensemble des
personnels vous au quotidien vous
ressent que au quotidien il ya des
efforts vraiment vraiment très important
et qui sont forcément se ressemblent pas
forcément sur leurs intentions sur les
étudiants sur les études bain
c'est à dire que les étudiants et des
craintes
évidemment pour la rentrée oui ça je
pense que toutes les familles doit y en
avoir qui regardent votre chaîne en ce
moment et qui se disent non est ce que
parce que notre et je pense que bon la
qualité de l'enseignement la qualité de
la recherche
elle n'est pas impacté pas pour
l'instant parce que ce sont des
processus à long terme quand même qu'ils
vont l'université a été construite avec
beaucoup d'engagement 1 de tous les
personnels mais mais bon il faudrait
quand même être prudent quand il faut
quand même faire attention
oui et puis et que l'engagement continu
c'est-à-dire que l'engagement de la part
des personnels mais voilà il est réel et
les quotidiens mais il faut qu'enfin
s'il ya un engagement aussi de la part
de l'état
non ça va pas donc oui vigilant
inquiétudes mais vigilance quand oui oui
enfin l'avenir n'est pas rose
c'est sûr et en plus il n'est pas
complètement clair c'est à dire qu'il ya
encore des zones de flou quand même et
encore des questions qui restent en
suspens et sur lesquels on demande
notamment la direction de l'université
de revenir et de faire un bilan vraiment
complètement à plat l'abonnement vous
avec la direction dit merci ne soit pas
présente ce soir soir il est vraiment
intéressant d'avoir un jeu mais comme la
merci merci en tout cas à vous trois
d'être venu sur le plateau télé filles
pour débattre de l'avenir de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
nous expliquer votre votre quotidien au
sein de cette université merci beaucoup
et bonne soirée